seth rogen says his working relationship
with james franco
is done after james was accused of
sexual misconduct
the duo worked together on several films
including the interview
pineapple express this is the end and
the disaster
artist which james won a golden globe in
2018.
uh yeah so it was right after james was
accused of sexual misconduct which
included asking female students at the
film school he founded
to act and perform in sexual scenes that
provide the normal safeguards for actors
and perform simulated sex
yeah and if students didn't agree they
were reportedly kicked off the shoot
which of course could damage their
standing with james at the school
seth has been called out as one of james
enablers and in 2018
seth said he would continue to work with
james
yeah but seth has changed his tune it's
been three years the two haven't shared
the screen again
and seth has no plans to so he told the
sunday times
what can i say is that i despise abuse
and harassment and
never cover or conceal the actions of
someone doing it
and knowingly puts someone in a
situation where they're around someone
like that
and when it comes to his private
relationship with james seth is more
vague saying
i don't know if i can define that right
now during this interview
i can say it um you know it has changed
many things in our relationship and our
dynamic
yeah but not as painful and difficult as
it is for a lot of other people involved
i have no pity for myself in this
situation
yeah county says james franco is so a
free spirit and
canceling him won't affect him yeah i
was gonna look up i don't think we've
seen
james on screen like anywhere like we
haven't seen james franco at all
in uh in a couple years like he's really
disappeared um
yeah his situation is uh is an odd one
because that's when we got into those
stories of
you know it wasn't just a clear case of
a kevin spacey arva or a harry weinstein
it was this um
really disturbing system
in place uh that yeah it's really hard
to crack and change but
yeah it was really a sad story if all
the allegations are true it was really a
sad story to hear because james
has been such a well-known figure and a
popular guy in hollywood
yeah it was sad because he's so
incredibly talented and that's something
you never want to hear about people
um but i feel for those students even
having to come out
experience that have to come out with
those allegations i don't know how it's
evolved since then
but you know it's difficult it's
difficult when you're friends with
somebody and you're close with somebody
and you work with them and you see them
you know
they're revered and you enjoy working
with them and you you laugh with them
and you bond with them
and then you hear a story like that and
you know maybe you ask them and they say
hey it's not true like i would never i
would never
and then you kind of take their side and
then it makes you look crazy i think at
the end of the day when someone is
accused of something so horrifying it's
important to do your research
because when you co-sign when you're
co-signing their behavior as well
and um you know set the such a huge name
so i think in that situation it was
important for him
to do as much research as he could and
understand it because when you're
co-signing somebody publicly it just
tells the world like hey i don't think
what they did is that bad and
it's not really fair to the people who
are victims um but
i mean it's nice that he's finally
saying something i have a feeling
they're still friends he's probably just
distancing himself from him uh publicly
yeah so i'm just looking at that james's
imdb so the deuce which is a
tv series that he was on like he was
still in episodes up to 2019 he was a
voice in the arctic dogs
he started a movie called kill czar last
year which i don't recall
um ceiling but yeah i mean he hasn't had
a high profile
um in any kind of sense i think it's got
a really
uh the writings on the wall a little bit
for james franco seth rogan i mean his
biggest collaborator when his big
supporters say i'm not going to work
with him i mean
if seth rogen isn't going to have your
back professionally i don't know where
james franco
uh goes from here um tony says without
fighting cancellation you look
uh guilty um and he says yeah they're
always a great uh duo together yeah they
always have a history
together but yeah i mean i yeah i don't
think james franco now that seth rogen
is saying this i don't think james
franco couldn't come back from him he's
been gone for
off the radar from dean's descent for a
couple years now so i don't think he can
come back from this
yeah and and there's still like so much
of an awakening happening in hollywood
like
just you know i started being in
hollywood
as a teenager and the way that it is now
it's it's gotten better but there's a
lot of things that happen in this town
in terms of like
just big names and you know drugs and
partying
and you know men not respecting women
and women throwing themselves at them or
women being taken advantage of whatever
it may be but there's a lot of things in
the party culture in hollywood
that is very um messed up and a lot of
it's not spoken about and you're seeing
pieces of it emerging and submerging and
we're seeing you know things like the
james franco thing like
that's not uncommon like that type of
stuff has happened
for so long but finally women are at the
point where they're like we've had
enough with this nonsense like we're
gonna speak out and people are rallying
behind them and it's
it's it's long overdue but there's just
so much of this that happens in
hollywood all the time so
um i'm just glad that it's being brought
to light and i think that people need to
be held accountable and make some
changes make this a safe place for
people like the world should just be a
safe place for people period
yeah and that's the thing like when
people say oh why don't they speak out
like think of the system if it's all
true i mean james starts his film school
you're a student at this film school he
asks you to shoot these
sex scenes and not wear the normal
protections like if you say no then
where's your standing at the school like
what's my career going to be if i say no
like fine i'll just get through it i
mean that that's kind of the system that
is
is set up so how do you say no in that
situation if you're trying to further
yourself in an industry so
yeah it's it's just a terrible situation
if it's all true once again but yeah
just a terrible situation that was
at that school yeah if it's all true and
also too it's like
a lot of people come to hollywood and go
to these film schools with these big
names
and they've left their their lives their
homes their families to
to you know grind in hollywood to make
their dream come true and then you
see someone like james franco who you
probably respected admire
and they tell you like you know this is
what we do you're not about this then
you're going to get the heck out they
got built for this like it's easy you
know people can be
impressionable in that way so yeah
there's a lot going on